[拍手]
[音楽]
またこんにちは
私はですね志というものは見つけるものではなくて皆さんが日々のこと一緒になること
によって心に作られるものだという話をしたと思っています
でそのために私の実際の実例私の経験を話すことによって何か皆さんの参考になると風
に思っています
で今日ここには日本語待って分からないといっても何かいらっしゃるということなので
その後に最後で英文少し話をします
でへと私の話なんですが今私は遠くに降りまして妻と一緒に住んでいるんですが
遠くのビジネスパーソンたちがですね本当にこう自分の能力とかビジネスキーを高める
ためにそういった仲間とも高める場所ということをつけようと思って思持ってこれは死
をもって今仙台で仕事をしていますそのきっかけは震災があって最初ボランティアで
遠くに参ったんですけれどもそこで強烈に自分が何ができるんだろうというふうに思い
もしました
その結果自分のそのビジネススクールがですね線なり学校をつくって話があったので手
を上げて私に使ってくださいということで
た新フレーバーとしてきました
今はその子らしを強く持って仕事をしてるんですけれども
5年経ちまして多くの皆さんがどうやってその子らしいって食べたんですかとかですね
あとそれとセットでよく私なかなかそういう暮らし見つけはないですよ見たナシをよく
されます
で私いつも自分のことを振り返るとですねその経験というかそのきっかけは自分の大学
時代からやったなと思います
私はの大学時代本当に苦しい時期がありました
それはですね
本当に何あればいいかわかんないっていう時期ですね
なあ体も健康だしまあ友達も多かったしなんか草サッカーとか臭いけどがありながら
暮らす出なかったんですけど
猫を日々が楽しいあの生活を悼みながらでもなんかふと考えると何をすればいいんだ
よってごまゆまゆ迷ってしまうと
周りの友達たちはみんなあの職場の就職活動を始めていくし
あと社会人たちがゆんですよ一生懸命なんかこう早く見つけろみたいな
やりたい事を見つけを直持ったなどと言うんですよねます中でどんどん自分を追い込ん
でいって苦しかったとそれに加えて私あの種子島の出身で親から仕送りしてもらって
ました
んなのでそのあの種子島の田舎でですね今
とに越してきまたら怖い親がですねそういう仕送りをしてまで私に効果音をくださるの
にどういう
何か見つけなきゃってこのすごい苦しい気持ちがあった
であるときも本当にクリすぎてもうたいけないってレベルまで苦しい気持ちになった時
にもうたいけないんで
あせめてその自分が関わっていることとか自分が興味を持っていることに対して
ちょっと踏み出して自分の目で見に行こう時に思いました
私の種子島の実家というのが和牛ですね黒毛和牛の農家やっていたのでじゃあその一つ
その黒毛和牛の農家まあ自分の足訪ねてそこでどんなことを勉強しようと思いました
まずやったことは日本人のその農家に電話しまくってですねアポとってですね合わせ
くださいって言って
で会いに行ったんですで八郎や答えるんですけどに悪くなかったあってくるし
何言ってもですねそのただ話だけじゃなくて一緒ご飯食べたり
あと一緒に農業したりとか時には彼の家に上がり込んで話をして飲んだりとかですね
そういうことを繰り返していく中で
日本の和牛農家の現状分かりました
わかったら次はどうも日本のは家協会展の早生の研究ての非常に大事になってることが
あったのでまた研究所電話をしてアボとって日本中の研究所もありました
検証回ると今度は日本の畜産業か分かるためには日本を出て海外から来にもみないと
分からないところを築いたんでこのオーストラリアに電話して調べですね大スライド
その和牛の
そういった組織のトップの方へ電話してすぐ合わせてくれっつって
で大瀬良に行きました
妖精入ったら今度はお皿いっぱい農家いることわかったんでまた重農日ぐらい前やポ
トって
ホームステイをしてそこでにあの大瀬良農業というのを勉強しましたのちくさんですね
そして大スウェーデ後勉強していると今度はその世界的なその
肉食の肉の食肉のその選手権があるって分かったんですなんか高格付けをするようなの
でそれに出るために日本代表しなきゃいけないんで日本に戻って今度は品川に東京品川
にあるその
食肉センターも特にまた連絡をして私を取りに来て下さいと言ってです
でトレーニングをしてもらって世界選手権に
にお礼としてました
そこまでいくと分かってきたことがどうもその日本とあのその王スレの農業の畜産の
違いというのは日本の農家というのは非常に来売り上げ重視
なんか隣の人にも誰か牛をつけることが大事だみたいななんかこう一番入って負けたく
ないにちょっとありの人に
とか大ステラ農家っていうのはコストと利益重視だから別にいくらで売れるかじゃなく
てどれだけできだした花にフォーカスをしていてその結果非常に高
違いが出たってのは勝ったそこまでわかった瞬間私は
やりきった感があったんですよ和牛に関しては自分やりきったっていう交通思いがなん
かねバエてきてよしこれでも終わろうというふうに思いました
就活が始まるそのときには自分がその和牛の経験で得たその財務とか経理が大事だって
いう思いをベースに就活初めてで日本で当時その非常に好財務経理に地下れている会社
があったのでそこに就職をして財務経理の仕事を始めました
ところですねあの入ってすぐに気づくんですねこれ際抜けあんま好きじゃないんだと
気づくんです
ところがですね気づいてもやっぱりやりきりたかったんですよね
そのはゲイの時に得たそのやりきる感っていうのをちゃんとやるんだということに月に
頑張りました
でやりきったタイミングで当時ですねあのその私が務めた財務経理の会社っていうのは
非常にそのリーダー育成に力を入れている会社だったので
そういったリーダー教育に貢献しようと思っていまのビジネスクリ転職をしたのが
3月1日でした第資産を10日前たんですね10日前
でその後のストーリーというのは冒頭申し上げたようにそこから8月金は東京で仕事を
したので土日は遠くに来てボランティアやってました
でそれを繰り返していくうちに仙台港作って話ができたのでそこに私が上院して
立ち上げを行いました
でそこで私が気付くのはその志はですねあの見つけようと思って探しておけば本当に
辛かったんです
どこにもしれないしなんか自分を見つけろって皆言うけどどこにもしれない
探せない
なのでだけど自分のやるべきこと目の前の仕事とか目の前の学業でもいいでしょうと
学生の方はいいと言いますけれども自分が少しでも興味あることとか関わっていること
を全力でやりきってみるそれやりきることを繰り返していくうちに自分の中にこれだし
ているのが出来上がってきました
なので今皆さんなんかこう回ってる方とかそういう苦しいを任せる方いらっしゃったら
是非
いったんその自分の暮らしを見つけるということは忘れて自分が取り組んでいることと
かもしくは自分は少しでも興味あることにもうちょっと踏み込んでやりきってほしい
そういうふうに思っています
どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]